qui craint le grand méchant loup c'est
la question que je vous pose ce soir et
oui vous avez pu reconnaître ce fameux
conte adapté par walt disney dans les
années 30 et dans lequel trois petits
cochons tente d'échapper à un méchant
loup le premier n'est fini construit une
maison en paille et cela fait détruire
par le loup qui souffle sur sa maison le
deuxième naf naf et une maison en bois
et finalement cela fait détruire
également et le troisième nous faut nous
faut se construit une maison en briques
bien solide et résistante et bien
aujourd'hui wilfrid peur maxime j'ai
quand même si je peux vous dire luz et
qui est les trois petits cochons ac qui
a ben je sais pas c'est un fait réel qui
moi je peux vous dire que l'histoire va
enfin donner raison à naf naf le petit
cochon qui construit sa maison en bois
oui puisque désormais ce type de maison
à construire ou à se faire construire
puisqu'on les deux sont possibles tente
de s'imposer sur le marché français et
tenez vous bien en construit même des
bâtiments de plusieurs étages
regardez ça vous n'allez pas en croire
vos yeux ça se passe à versailles c'est
une résidence étudiants et on a bien
accroché à embauche pas bien accroché
1-1 par croire nos cieux bienvenue à la
fresque une résidence universitaire
versaillaise de 60 logements
actuellement en construction implantée
aux abords de l'université versailles
saint quentin
sa caractéristique est d'être construite
principalement en bois
la plateforme elle est réalisée en béton
parce qu'elle sert sr structurellement à
réaliser certains porte-à-faux certaines
figures architectural après au dessus de
cette plate forme dont convient tout
simplement faire un peu comme avec des
capes là pour les jeux d'enfants
organisé des refend les voiles de façade
on posait plancher par dessus des caps
là en gros et puis on élève comme ça
quatre étages des bâtiments
on a été je pense longtemps bloqué dans
la construction bois parce qu'on n'y
voyait des éléments fragiles on avait
peur du feu on avait et caetera et
s'aperçoit que techniquement on a
répondu à beaucoup de réponses à dessus
on a des bâtiments qui sont pas moins
résistants au feu quelquefois même mieux
on a des bâtiments qui sont largement
aussi solide on a on a un confort
naturellement en matière d'isolation
qu'on n'avait pas obligatoirement avec
certains types de construction autre
avantage le chantier permet de faire
fonctionner des entreprises françaises
spécialisées dans la filière bois
chaque appartement mesure environ 20
mètres carrés on y retrouve une entrée
avec kitchenette une chambre et une
salle de bains accessibles aux personnes
en situation de handicap
le chauffage se fait par le sol
l'étudiant peut le régler via un
thermostat
coût total de l'opération un peu plus de
5 millions d'euros
fin des travaux prévue pour la rentrée
2013 il s'agit d'une première expérience
à versailles si elle s'avère positive la
ville n'exclut pas de construire
d'autres bâtiments de ce type sous
réserve de trouver les terrains et c'est
donc la maison de naf naf que nous avons
visités ce soir c'est bien ça si j'ai
tout suivi à votre chronique tout à fait
mûr fait sauf qu'elle s'appelle la
fresque voilà c'est le c'est le nom
qu'on lui a donné c'était plus sympa que
neuf mais moi j'ai proposé on m'a pas
écouté on écoute plus mais la fresque
pourquoi pas tout simplement parce que
il va y avoir sur un des pans de murs
une fresque dessinée par des enfants de
la maison de quartier voisine à cet
établissement
alors on a pu le voir dans le reportage
quand on est à l'intérieur finalement
rien ne différencie vraiment ce logement
d'un autre l'isolation est fait en laine
de verre
l'habillage avec des plaques de plâtre
type b à 13 les bricoleurs connaîtront
dans le reportage l'architecte parlait
de jeux de construction vous connaissez
les caps les camions fils c'est aussi
simple que ça à construire c'est
vraiment aussi simple système en fait il
s'agit de mettre les uns sur les autres
des blocs de ce type on va les voir tout
de suite ce qu'on appelle des blocs leno
alors pour simplifier il s'agit
d'espèces de grosses plaques de
contreplaqué
sauf que l' avantage avec la
construction ne nécessite pas de gros
engins de chantier et surtout ne fait
pratiquement aucun bruit
c'est comme les lego mais avec ses
records et rigoler noah alors en plus
cela vous avez vu le bâtiment est situé
dans un endroit où il y avait déjà
d'autres bâtiments donc il aurait fallu
que des camions se faufile qu'on amène
des grues de chantier serait était
bruyant sera été embêtant pour le
voisinage pratiques pourraient pour le
voisinage là c'est vraiment très
pratique d'autant plus que le le
chantier en plus c est beaucoup plus
court qu'un chantier classique pourquoi
parce que le c'est un système sait qu il
n'y a pas de béton donc pas besoin de
rajouter dos on peut travailler même si
pleut alors que s'il ya du béton bas le
béton il faut que ça sèche c'est combien
de temps par exemple pour cette
résidence universitaire les travaux ont
débuté il ya à peu près six mois un
petit peu plus longtemps oui un
programme bien ça se finira à la rentrée
2013 voilà les premiers étudiants
pourront entrer à la rentrée 2013
bon bien sûr il n'y a pas que des
avantages j'ai posé la question à daniel
thibault qu'on a vu tout à l'heure dans
le reportage qui est l'un des
architectes nous donne quelques
inconvénients écouter des inconvénients
on a avec de l'acier ou du béton des
capacités importantes qui sont qui sont
très intéressantes qui permettent
justement de travailler des figures qui
sont peu chères aux architectes les
porte à faux ou des grands
franchissement elle peut penser aux
vieilles halles en béton pensez aussi à
des bâtiments plus plus administratif
donc oui c'est peut-être sa contrainte
c'est structurellement c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut réfléchir un peu un peu
différemment
donc là on a bien compris pas question
par exemple de construire des grandes
halles en bois pour ce type de
d'édifices publics diront nous deux de
taille assez importante il faudra
continuer de construire en béton pour
l'instant en tout cas on ne savait pas
la technologie ont peut-être évoluer par
la suite je me suis posé une question
qui prend tout son sens dans le cadre de
la ville de versailles
et si l'expérience réussit et que les
bâtiments en bois se multiplient et bien
que vont penser les habitants mais oui
ses habitants c'est versailles et qui
sont tellement attachés à leur
patrimoine
rappelez vous un peu le scandale de
bernar venet le ferrailleur comme on
l'appelait qui avait installé brassé
plus à oui c'est un peu plus discret
mais bon on ne sait jamais c'est une
ville quand même assez classique une
ville 18e qui a grandi avec louis xiv
donc il faut conserver un certain ça
fait beaucoup de préjugés maxime non
c'est parce que j'ai vécu à versailles
et j'ai côtoyé beaucoup de versailles et
et je peux comprendre qu'on souhaite
garder voilà une certaine côté
historique
versailles est bien à cette question
voici ce que m'a répondu le président de
l'office hlm de versailles habitat il
s'agit de michel bancal selon lui il n'y
a pas du tout de problème
d'ailleurs même le bo a fait presque
partie intégrante de l'histoire de
versailles écoutez ça l'aspect extérieur
du bâtiment ne dépasse ne dépend pas du
tout sa structure ses terres que vous
pouvez même si ça n'a pas où il ya moins
d'intérêt fantastique
on peut très bien imaginer d'avoir un
bâtiment structure bois qui en extérieur
sont apathiques 18e surtout à versailles
quand vous connaissez la construction
versaillaise à l'exception du château et
de l'église et de quelques monuments
publics
la quasi-totalité du bâti 18e c'est
l'ossature - c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les
maisons de versailles c'est des maisons
à pans de bois dans lequel on
remplissait avec du tout venant et donc
c'est bien ce droit à versailles alors
alors il ya énormément de bâtiments
surtout dans les quartiers notre dame et
les quartiers saint louis qui sont parmi
les plus vieux quartiers de versailles
on trouve beaucoup de bâtiments de ce
type
certains d'ailleurs malheureusement ne
sont pas bien entretenu parce que les
propriétaires pas forcément toujours les
moyens de payer les travaux sont souvent
des bâtiments qui sont demandées des
appartements qui sont des familles
depuis très longtemps
donc voilà y'a pas car au lieu ressource
pour votre tour à tour s'il y avait hier
de tous ces bâtiments il n'a pas fallu
attendre les écolos finalement pour
construire des bâtiments en bois on peut
le dire est en tout cas si le procédé
vous intéresse sachez que vous
particulier vous pouvez aussi faire
construire votre propre maison en bois
est oui selon l'observatoire économique
de france bois forêt en 2011 plus de
quinze mille maisons ont été construites
ce qui représente environ un peu plus de
11 % des nouveaux logements individuels
satané annonce déjà pas mal commence à
être conséquent et sachant que la france
a quand même un peu de retard sur
certains voisins par exemple aux états
unis on parle de 90 % de nouveaux
logements construits en bois
chaque année donc c'est quand même des
chiffres fait plus qu'un effet de mode
c'est beaucoup plus conséquent
alors les avantages sont globalement les
mêmes que pour un bâtiment quelques on a
vu tout à l'heure à savoir l'impact sur
l'environnement donc l'impact écologique
à condition évidemment d'utiliser du
bois provenant de forêts où l'on
replante systématiquement dès qu'on
coupe un arbre sont des forêts qui sont
gérés évidemment pour un bilan carbone
positive
il vaut mieux privilégier des forêts à
proximité du lieu où on va construire
son logement pour éviter le transport
éviter la pollution
ça permet également une meilleure
isolation en comparaison avec le béton
l'isolation thermique est dix fois plus
efficace avec le bois une rapidité de
construction l'a entendue dans le sujet
tout à l'heure sachez d'ailleurs que
certaines personnes choisissent de
construire elle-même leur maison avec
des matériaux qu'elle commandait alors
là pour le coup c'est vraiment un vrai
jeu de construction
bon il ya différents styles et l'instar
qui allait les plaques de bois qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure ça peut être également
d'aider des grands ronds d'un conte en
boîte les uns sur les autres
rim est sûr de soi avant de se lancer à
bien sûr mais il ya quand même pas mal
de gens qui se vous savez cette cette
vague un peu écolo cette vague un peu
verte qu'on connaît depuis une dizaine
d'années en france a fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'émules
donc il ya quand même des gens qui
n'hésitent pas à se lancer
c'est également une maison qui est
évolutive en effet il est beaucoup plus
facile d'abattre enfin de démonter un
mur en bois que d'abattre un mur en
béton dont par exemple imaginons voilà
vous avez construit votre maison un
petit coup de 6,1 matière marcy jeu sur
le moment j'avais pas les moyens pour
construire ma véranda bombe a coûté là
je me la démonte maintenant et puis hop
je construis une véranda que je mets au
bout et enfin l'adaptive et
l'adaptabilité chez oui je m'adapte
aussi compte tenu du faible poids la
structure en bois peut s'adapter à des
terrains difficiles faible portance ou
forte pente
par exemple eh oui structure quand même
très légère donc par exemple sur un
terrain qui n'auraient pas forcément
tenu de permis de construire parce que
trop une inter trônera trop meuble et
bat pour une maison en bois c'est
beaucoup plus simple aurait pas
d'inconvénient à si bien sûr vous savez
bien que moi je effectivement je aller
trop bouger à la
h mais je ne fais pas de langue de bois
il apparaissait trop beau les
inconvénients on a il s'agit par exemple
de bien choisir ses matériaux même sens
tout seul il faut consulter un
spécialiste c'est très important
par exemple pour éviter l'humidité ou
l'apparition de champignons tous les
bois ne résident toutes les essences de
bois ne résiste pas de la même manière
au climat oui parce que ça dépend
également de la partie du monde où la
partie de la france ou dans laquelle
vous vous trouvez
attention également aux insectes
certains types de bois ne les attire pas
mais d'autres nécessitent traitement
donc évidemment progression pratique il
vaut mieux acheter directement un type
de bois qui n'attire pas les insectes
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus simple
inde et rapidement dernier conseille
alors un dernier conseil
je vous parlais de quelque chose que
valence et ikea enfin en tout cas c'est
une rumeur
c'est une rumeur vous connaissez ce
grand constructeur aimable on va
vraiment et ça m'a bien ton est monté
c'est raison ça s'appelle bo clock
céline forcément c'est gai c'est une
maison en kit une maison low cost il ya
beaucoup de rumeurs depuis quelques
années qui disent que le géant suédois
va tenter de s'implanter en france en
tout cas sachez que en scandinavie les
maisons beau clock fonctionne vraiment
très bien en 3500 maisons labellisé
bâtiment basse consommation beaux clubs
sont construits dans les écoquartiers
chaque année ça se passe en scandinavie
et on verra si l'avenir vous donne
raison c'est justement ça se développe
merci maxime pour cette chronique de
l'environnement vous retrouverez la
semaine prochaine toujours en forme bien
évidemment le président de la chambre
syndicale des buralistes des yvelines va
venir sur ce plateau
juste après ce reportage consacré à la
vente aux enchères d'une partie des
biens de la communauté d'agglomération
alice gastines
équipez vous sans vous ruiner
voilà le mot d'ordre lancé par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour écouler
son mobilier
suite à son déménagement de montigné
attrape particularité il s'agit d'une
vente aux enchères la quatrième du genre
depuis le mois de juin
il faut s'inscrire c'est gratuit et
ensuite on sélectionne les biens qui
nous intéresse et on enchérit valeur par
pas de 10% des prix affichés et à la fin
de l'enchère donc le dernier
enchérisseur le meilleur enchérisseur
est déclarée enchérisseurs également
nous avons l'intention de déménager
donc on va avoir en train 66 m² on passe
à 130
donc évidemment il nous faut il faut
remplir
on va avoir une très très grande pièce
qui va nous servir du bureau donc on
cherche des petits meubles pas trop cher
donc ici il faut reconnaître que les
prix d'appel sont quand même intéressant
ouverte le 5 septembre cette vente aux
enchères concernent aussi quatre
voitures des tables de cantine et des
luminaires ici les personnes intéressées
peuvent voir en vrai le mobilier mis en
vente
on a vu ça sur internet bazar un petit
peu et puis ben du coup ça nous a donné
envie de venir voir quand même avant de
faire des enchères de voir quand même un
petit peu l'état du matériel parce que
sur les photos on va très très bien
quand même
il a fallu inventorié répertoriés et
photographier tout le mobilier un
travail laborieux mais payant les trois
premières vagues ont permis d'écouler
174 éléments le bilan de cette dernière
vente sera connu le 16 septembre date de
clôture des enchères